davis luca marrone herren herzlich
willkommen ja heute zu einer weiteren
episode des fonds sind so macht's nicht
nur youtube deutschland sondern weltweit
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einer
weiteren folge
die betten
die folge ein ball um die ecke kippt um
ja das kann ja nur toll werden
meinberger schreit auf einer kugel sind
keine ahnung aber ich glaube du wirst es
mir jetzt beantworten diesel schreiber
wir schauen uns erst mal ein nicht
wipfel video an
[Musik]
man wollte mich komplett verarschen utah
ich bin wirklich du solltest becker
werden er war der nicht auch schon in
der letzten luca reagiert folge mit
dabei die heiße kurven fahrrad murat
ok cool also du bist jetzt wieder mit
dabei dann wird's in der letzten folge
war ja ja der war ausbaufähig nur
allerdings herzlich willkommen zurück
hier auch in dieser folge luca reagiert
m yours mehr empfohlen becker zu werden
warum denn kann es mir das bitte mal
erläutern den und youtube kriegst du
nichts gebacken
wow wirklich also echt mega geil was ihr
da immer raus was ist der unterschied
zwischen fußgängern und fuß okay er hat
sogar ein zweiter witz am start
was ist der unterschied zwischen
fußgängern und fußballspielern ich habe
ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung die
fußgänger gehen bei grün die
fußballspiele bei rot regt die nicht auf
lukas alles gut wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten video
kula zug war ja recht zügig versteht ihr
wegen zog besonders die du wissen musst
grund kann ich liegen und parkplatz mit
diesem klub jetzt einen neuen tiefpunkt
erreicht wir sind mittlerweile nicht
mehr auf der höhe des erdkerns sondern
wir sind mitten im örtchen was ist
trauen kann nicht fliegen und fritzchen
um die ecke was fehlt ich darf nicht
aufhören gegen den urheberrecht da wollt
ihr mich eigentlich alle komplett
verarschen wer hat euch denn in euren
humor geschützen treffen sich zwei alte
damen sagt ja eigentlich hatte man erst
mal mit 18 sagt die andere ich hatte
mein erstes mal nur einen kicker sind
mein erstes mal mit 18 euro ich hatte
mein erstes mal mit nur einem du
bekommst von mir wirklich in win der
woche
ich weiß nicht ob ich froh sein soll
weil es endlich ein video ist das keinen
dummen witz beinhaltet oder ob ich
weinen soll
weil die toilette echt hardcore ekelhaft
aussieht aber gut man weiter mit dem
nächsten video die datei auf jeden fall
ein bisschen größer und das video
dementsprechend auch ein bisschen länger
also ich bin gespannt ob da etwas
professionelles auf uns wartet hast du
unterschied zwischen einem ein makake
und luca luka stinken die karte sieht
besser aus
die kacke ist können auch die kacke
stinkt mehr
sie sieht besser aus und sie ist kein
laub mal schauen was die richtige
antwort war ja da hat natürlich nicht
dass unsere ist keine frage allerdings
ist es nicht dass noch was ist
eigentlich an hinauswollte
unterschiedlichen einmal kam luca ist
natürlich sagen erkennt sie 1 alles klar
was ist der unterschied zu einer
[Musik]
wirklich so das ist einfach pure kunst
was ihr hier ein sendet eine blondine
brünette springer aus dem flugzeug wer
kommt er an genau die projekte und die
blondine muss es nach dem weg frage und
wieder muss erst nach dem weg fragen
ich blogge ich nicht ich auf eine
normale community haben ding das man
hier meine bücher merge oder zettel mit
meinem namen drauf aus dem fenster
schmeißt bin ich cool wirklich
[Musik]
ja ich will
video an der stelle dann auch beenden
ich möchte schlichtweg nicht dass ich
eure lehrer die tage bei mir melden von
wegen wurde in eure ganzen gehirnzellen
hin sind wenn es euch gefallen hat las
gern like darunter im video schickt mir
eure videos gern an videos and laser
luca punkt com
und was ist grün kann nicht fliegen
[Musik]